can't be garbage at The Gramercy
New York City a couple of picks left for
that Friday show oh yeah Dang if we're
in the tri-state area do yourself a
favor grab some tickets come see at the
grammar theater we can't wait yeah it's
live stand up me and the big man
co-headline then we play ayg with the
crowd you've seen the clips it's a good
time the Army garbage coming correct
sold out almost three shows some tickets
left get them now let's party welcome so
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find it as a
group to be classy yeah they're just a
big old piece of trash trash I'm your
hostage coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antuti's basement
she's upstairs finger banging herself
in the goddamn living room
my co-host is coming at you across the
table
he is the CEO of are you garbage he is
an international businessman gonna be
ringing the bell
over at P.S 13 in Queens get the school
day started okay give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan hey what's up that might be
the best hoodie of all time that [__]
knocked my socks off because I pictured
it immediately uh what's up everybody
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate if
you subscribe on iTunes you got the full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are
and then speaking of cooking we're gonna
have to hire another line line Chef down
there for the fire for the fudge and
patreon down there uh
www.patreon.com are you garbage yeah you
can sign up you get bonus episodes ayg
and episodes of the barn burner hard
feelings uh you get all the bonus video
we do we do a monthly uh uh thing of on
the road we got a new guy Luke doing
that oh my God about bajillion hours of
content on there you know it that's
legally binding check it out good time
over there gang how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works those ones Works those twos
crosses them T's dots them eyes it's
T-Bone McMuffin
Toby McMullen everybody what's up dude
what up T-Bone I'm glad our
conversations about the new YouTube
terms of service have fallen upon deaf
ears I didn't curse I changed the fudge
you said finger banging in the first 10
seconds that's not a curse word
they can't send you their principal's
office went back it ain't dinner talk
I'll tell you that much
that's getting flagged at Sunday supper
you can't drop finger banging in front
of your mom just dumping finger popping
I don't know what we're talking about
gag we're here for a family episode it's
just the boys this week we're hanging
out we're gonna be doing some patreon
questions we're going to be goofing
around but first Kevin Ryan with the
weather
what's going on with you in the uh I
don't like this but what do you got I
don't like this at all the crew neck
sweaters sweatshirts you've been rocking
recently I've worn two in a week I don't
think that's you know it's a sweatshirt
I don't understand man all right next
story up mean what what did you
what do they bother you I think it's a
pretty solid normal uh it's just old
school it's just it's very 90s ladies
and gentlemen that's a great example of
the H Foley Playbook when you got
nothing throw your friend under the bus
I know hey I heard you've been wearing
shirts
work for the Republicans in the 90s
still works today baby
I mean we have a when in doubt trash the
other guy I drag him you want to throw
it all right that's the kind of campaign
it's going to be you want to start
throwing mud I'll throw mud
I got a bad case of mud butt
um we obviously have a track uh show
about uh you know trash Behavior sure
things sure can we mention
that it's been 23 days since the live
stream and we still have cups of uh milk
with dinner over there sitting on the
bed sitting on the date dude there is
fermented chocolate milk in all of those
glasses we haven't cleaned up in here
once in 23 days we got the covid Cure
sitting right there and I can see the
spores multiplying over there yeah
that's bad little spaceships are going
to be flying out of there that
Civilization is going to be more
advanced than us in a couple of days
yeah I mean that's next level Dirtbag
[__] we just have old Yoo-hoo and vodka
there's no sinks down here I know I mean
I don't want those glasses those that's
nice stemware that's got to be thrown
out it's Johnny Walker black uh
commemorative gear I'm gonna throw that
out oh what are you just gonna let it
sit over there and grow mold
somebody will figure it out yeah me
that's what it's going to be we need a
sink there's a dude there's a bathroom
I'm not washing cups in the bed that's
trash washing cups in the bathroom we're
gonna have to throw them out which I've
done every move I've ever done I've just
tossed all the dirty dishes oh yeah all
the dude pots with like at the house
yeah you did any move oh move forget
about it yeah oh I'll throw something
off if it gets too too Grody burn the
place to the ground if I even mid mid
Middle East if something gets too nasty
and I go why the [__] are we saving up
you throw it out buy a new one on Amazon
eight bucks whatever it is you guys ever
have to boil water when you were a kid
you ever get a drink yeah no I didn't
grow up in Guam what are you talking
about boil water to drink what year did
you grow up you never had something
gonna happen with the neighborhood or
something boil water for a couple of
days nah dude we didn't live on the
Oregon Trail yeah what are you talking
about we did nothing yeah you got a well
no
are you using correct water what do you
got what are you working with what are
you boiling dude that's not smooth
what's going on yeah I remember we had I
think my mom had to do it recently where
they were like stay away from the water
for a couple of days or boil it some
main broke or something like that like
that I mean an incident maybe yeah yeah
yeah but I remember as a kid we had to
do that for a couple days something was
going on
and I remember it was something with the
bathroom I remember a buddy of mine
growing up had well issues where he was
growing up and uh which they say is good
which we obviously found out is
naturally purified to the Limestone or
whatever that it's in
um yeah it's a little dead squirrel
Falls in there close up the well well
went bad uh I'm a city main kind of guy
tap me into a heavy bike Maine I don't
want squirrel teeth in my iced tea run
something through some filters for me
[Laughter]
I've been leaning on just just the
straight water in the house now
the Brit is a pain in the ass dude buddy
I'm telling you I upgraded my life I was
thinking about it today I got the five
gallon jugs they drop it off you know
what my my wife likes sparkling I get
hurt two cases of Pellegrino and that's
what we do there's you know those
Europeans they like those bubbles yeah
they do I haven't drank a glass of water
and no joke over a month that's crazy
what are you talking about I just drink
seltzer that's water that's what I say
that's rich guy water that's what that
is Club soda's all right I'm not sure
the difference between Seltzer club soda
and one has a little salt in it what one
Selter really yep huh and then what's
tonic has quinine in it whoa ah well
went bad or what happened
I don't know but I love tonic water when
I was a kid and I would do vodka tonics
in college brutal well vodka that's what
my brother was drinking I thought so I
started drinking it man talk about a
hang I was on gnt's for a little bit gin
and tonic gnt's and cools I was smoking
are you a jazz musician
gin and tonics and cool it's about a
Cadillac yeah
for a couple weeks in college you're
getting after it
oh that's really trying to find an
identity in college that's really trying
to figure out who you are got a fedora
on you're playing the sacks yo gen socks
tonic sucks but together it's real nice
yeah I don't hang over City though no
good gin come on man what are you doing
that almost brought down the British
Empire oh [__]
bunch of water heads can't be drinking
that [__]
um
[__] what was I gonna say did you Google
did you fact check me on the Seltzer uh
uh Seltzer versus club soda club soda
has the addition of potassium
bicarbonate and potassium sulfate in the
water yeah that's that did you guys
drink that growing up I mean we only had
it for mixers and dry drunks that's what
we had what tonic or club soda there was
always a tonic in there yeah there was a
little glass bangers we had left over
from you know yeah there was a series a
couple of Seagram's Jimmy let's get
after it
Uncle Jimmy loved you
well too much if you know what I mean
now we had those but I remember coming
in [__] looking through all the
cabinets looking through the
refrigerator nothing to drink and it was
either chug and milk which I was okay
with all that which did quench your
thirst oh yeah it fills you too so good
it's like a meal and a drink or you'd
find an old bottle of tonic water in the
back that was uh that was flat just
crushed that going in it's okay there's
there's a metallic aftertaste afterwards
that would set off a nine-year-old
palette like a smoke alarm drinking
that's like snake bite shots be [__]
those those bite back those tonic Waters
they got a little bit of a bite though
you know what my wife's been doing she's
been ordering she's on she does raw milk
did we really she orders it from Amish
people she got it yeah she got her hand
I don't know if I'm legally allowed it's
illegal in New York yeah it's fine
that's dicey that's a carnivore MD's
always talking about raw milk yeah he
makes a lot of sense man keeps it tight
though tight little body on that guy
yeah
um I looked into raw milk yeah you have
to go to Jersey to get it and you get
the hook up from the Amish
um
which I don't trust those Amish nobody
with that bed of a haircut
um get out of here buddy what are you
doing grab a mirror what the [__] is
this all about
walking around judging me they always
got they all they always look like
they're looking up and down like you're
on your way to hell buddy hey hit a hair
cuttery
Sport Cuts or something
Great Clips you look like a [__]
[__] grab a pair of Clippers will you
I mean you got you you sheared a sheep
why don't you run why don't you do a
flyby on that [__] Sheamus on the bike
and charge that thing up
[__] why don't you do a Passover on
those bangs man it's [__] 2023.
you're a 24 year old man with bangs what
are we doing uh there's a there's a dice
being rolled with that though with what
with the with the uh raw milk oh it's
better for you but then I don't like the
fact that it's botulism or something I
don't like the fact it's in the house I
don't like it really if it's what are we
doing what'd she say how it tastes I
know she got something else there's
another concoction that they make that
there's she that made her gag there's
low heat pasteurized I don't know cream
top milk no no this is more like a
yogurt kefir yes yeah Ari kefir she got
a couple Ari shaffir's kefir she got a
couple of times she got a couple tubes
of that it made her gag so she gave it
to the dog and made him puke in the
living room so I'm like this I'll get
this Amish [__] out of my house okay you
can't get a dog yogurt no it's good for
him apparently it's good for the
microbiome or some [__] I don't know
what's the scoop Dogg uh raw milk
because milk that has not been
pasteurized to kill harmful bacteria raw
milk can carry harmful germs such as
campylobacter
could barely know her what are you
talking about
crypto sporidium I'm a bit man Bitcoin
man E coli listeria brucella and
salmonella yeah that's if like the dirty
finger that's not the milk itself I
think that's how it's processed and I
think the reason why they started
pasteurizing it was because
Louis Pasteur they were damn their hands
were dirty they know hand sanitizer but
if it's done and I don't think the Amish
are playing [__] you know they're out
there with the dung beetle and stuff
I think they do I think you have to get
to it pretty quick the shelf life ain't
great it's like a carnival goldfish you
got to get that in you quick we got
tagged in a new Bev that seems Reckless
what there's the the monster energy is
releasing their alcoholic beverage yeah
oh I know let's go I smell a new sponsor
what I'm talking about monsters hit me
up Monster Energy Drink raw milk and
vodka
package it all together they don't check
your ID they just look for neck tattoos
yeah you haven't taken a sip of this
milk you're [__] nuts really no not
I'm not drinking someone who's hand
delivered by a guy with a bad haircut
all right do you have to shake it up I
don't know man I I I don't even like
going in the fridge anymore I want to
try right I'm just scared come over you
two can throw up together that's right
from the titties sip it on some milk
tartar nah
I like to pasteurized but you're not
getting as good it's got really good
stuff in it really good for you yeah
according to that guy yeah accordingly
yeah all right I don't know man I don't
like it I'm you know it is what it is
I don't you know she doesn't like all
the things I do I don't think 19 cores
lights are any better than raw milk so I
didn't know you were scoring it yeah
what were they getting you for I don't
know probably ain't cheap I don't know
they ship it up from PA or something
whole milk allegedly Whole Foods has has
uh low low heat pasteurized which is
pretty good apparently uh I don't know
I'm a [__] whole milk
goat's milk is pretty good oh oh no what
are we talking about goat cheese maybe
on a salad that's got a little must to
it though
sometimes you get a cheese I remember
the first time I had attention I almost
[__] shot the block up
yeah what are you putting in your
Cheddar dude I know that's rough it's
got air in it
I don't trust goats either doing cheddar
all day now just do that I don't trust
goat I don't like goats they're eyes the
[__] is that real quick do you ever see
those videos of the guy going in to feed
them and yet they get [__] hey run up
on you like the Bloods and the grips
they don't play around
you gotta keep your head on a swivel if
you're in a goat pen pretend like
they're broke down you stop they rob you
yeah get in the car do you ever see them
they have like you know they they pass
out or whatever yeah that's playing dead
they come over yeah they [__] you
pop up with some nickels
come up off that feed [__] what the
[__] yeah I don't like the way their
eyes are shaped it's real devilish real
demon yeah well that isn't like the
goat's head is like on the you know
yeah I don't like that guy a yellow kid
a rag king or whatever he was big into
goat heads I don't yeah oh just give me
right [__] straight up milk of
something for you what the regular stuff
the pasteurizer I'm cranking heaters
like they're illegal all right milk
ain't my problem
alcohol get raw heaters from the Amish
these aren't stepped on these are
illegal in New York don't tell no one I
got them a couple of roll roll Stingers
cord cop pipe
we gotta meet a guy in a back alley
good stuff all right let's quit screwing
around geez quit screwing around here
you gotta you got a hot show we gotta do
gang it's a family episode as you know
when you sign up for the old patreon
there you get a question right on the
air uh-huh
uh this one's from Gary abusive uh uh
okay I don't know if that's a government
name
it says in the world of one of ours but
I've never this is a different take on
it which is very good which might make
the circulation this is a good one ten
dollar homie never have on red are you
garbage if your house has been on the
news
[Laughter]
if your house has been on the news for
something like an explosion or you know
it ain't good a sinkhole or something
[Laughter]
trampoline accident yeah when the Earth
Eats your house sinkholes are [__]
dude scared that happened in West Philly
on the Boulevard in like the 80s it dude
it just took like three whole blocks and
we would drive by you just see them it'd
be like three four feet in the ground
there was a sinkhole out in front of the
house that I lived on on Ditmars really
right as I was that happens in New York
right I just gotta drive around there
right as I was moving out I walked out
and I'm like what the [__] and I looked
and I could like see like a hole and I'm
like yo that ain't good like ah don't
worry about it the next day it was like
it was like a [__] like a in-ground
swimming pool yeah they don't I remember
that I think yeah yeah they don't now
that and uh whatchamacult
um manhole covers blowing up that
happened on 42nd Street not too long
after 9 11 scared the [__] out of
everybody yeah I think killed one poor
guy that was right over top of it I
flicked I flicked a Bernie the other day
and it rolled and dropped down the hole
they say you're not supposed to do that
what flick Bernie's in the in manhole
covers or I wasn't I mean I didn't or
sewer grates I don't do it on purpose
typically whatever the wind called it
and she you know I called a hanger dog
leg left and she she banged the left and
went down that hole in the manhole and
in my head I was like that could [__]
run it's a methane gas that'll [__] him
that'll wake up the block
Kaboom
uh great question yeah that's good uh
let's see here uh this is from Jennifer
ten dollar homie never have one red is
it garbage if you have to put the
parental control lock on QVC so your
wife can't order anything off the TV man
oh man talk about getting it they're
still getting you I get man they're
probably better than ever they're
marketers they've learned it's not like
the QVC from the 80s these people are
sharp now it's like they got the
algorithm figured out but who's watching
that how old is this guy his wife's
watching QVC QVC's huge Lori from Shark
Tank QVC queen that probably does like
10 billion dollars a year see the the
hot one yeah yes shout out the Barb too
I don't know the old broad yeah the
queen of New York City real estate yeah
tight little Keystone yeah Lori's all
right they're all all right what I have
a shot with her Lori yeah nah I picky
was a Mr Wonderful kind of guy all right
take me out to a nice dinner and in
perpetuity
that guy's always taking points on the
back end he goes yellow me fifty dollars
a unit forever
who's your favorite shark
uh it's funny you mentioned that because
I never [__] with that show oh I I've
seen everyone about 10 times when I was
when it was when it was on I don't even
know when it was on I think it's bigger
now that it's ever been yeah they don't
still make it today yeah it's hotter
than ever is it always on MSNBC or
whatever it is no they're all reruns oh
they are I think the new ones are an NBA
NBC proper oh yeah I watch it on MSNBC
yeah uh reruns I don't know what's going
on I can't tell when it is or who who's
new or whatever my favorite shark would
be yeah probably Mr Mr Mr Fantastic Mr
Wonderful Mr fan what's he a wrestler
elbow dropping yeah he's all right but
they're all cool as [__] they're not
dicks I thought they were going to be
more dicks I like Cuban Cuban Cuban's
all right he can be a dick though
because he's a businessman he's he's got
a big ego and they call him out for it
he tells people to shut up try selling
try to come out and pitch vitamins to
him he he's got your number that's fake
science he screams at people he don't he
don't play that [__] what do you think
QVC generated in one year Revenue wise
eight billion dollars uh oh yeah eight
billion 2 billion 14.2 Billy look at
that that's what I'm saying dude they
move Uni's yeah Stranglehold in the
midwest
everybody's buying that [__] dude
everyone who's sitting there watching TV
like that they got good party
I'm telling you dude okay let's talk
about that Adam and Eve baby
I got a hard on right now
who doesn't one of our favorite sponsors
here on the show and let's be honest
gang Valentine's Day is coming up oh
yeah sure the spark has gone down a
little bit you know what cures that what
sticking something up your butt uh-huh
or putting your peter in something
whatever you want to do nothing wrong
with it uh-huh uh our listeners get 50
off almost any item just use the code
garbage at checkout you'll get 50 off
plus free shipping that's 50 off an
adventurous new toy a slippery Lube or
almost anything else you desire to cram
in your b-hole uh it's also it's great
they send it send her out with the
girlfriends have a good time by yourself
yeah you know start plugging away on
yourself I don't care what you do hey
it's 200 2 20 23 I looked the other way
whatever whatever you know uh no matter
how big your package ends up being it
will be sent discreetly and for free to
have a happy Valentine's Day go to
adamandeve.com select any one item and
use the code garbage this is an
exclusive inclusive offer so be sure to
support the show and use code garbage to
get 50 off at a hundred percent free
shipping go to adamandeve.com right now
do it lube it up Kevin I'm going to tell
you about liquid IV I love liquid IV I'm
gonna tell you about a personal
experience that I had recently okay 103
degree temperature 24 hour bug knocked
me out you know what I was sucking down
the whole time that got me through it
I'm telling you right now scotch and
sodas
liquid IV baby yeah man had that in my
water bottle I'm telling you it was like
Mother's Milk the whole time kept me
hydrated kept me going I was dreaming
about it when I was falling asleep yeah
I can't recommend enough if you had a
rough night or you're working out do
yourself a favor get on that liquid IV
save my life yeah use it uh first thing
in the morning before workout or on Long
flights it's free from gluten dairy and
soy liquid IV contains three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks plus it tastes delicious goddamn
delicious uh grab your local IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20
off when you go to liquid iv.com use the
code garbage to check out support the
guys that support the show there you go
that's 20 off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
the promo code garbage out one more time
get a pen get a pencil write her down
liquid iv.com
do it let's see this one's from oh this
is a killer named Burger wolf 69.
that's all right you need a guy taken
out you called a burger oh dude the
Burger King I feel like that's just
fully [__] alter ego
what are you doing all this ground beef
all the burger
next time next time we go out to dinner
the police like table for four under
Burger wolf please
ah Mr Burger wolf Right This Way full
moon tonight the burger wolf will get
you
oh shout out to them you have to squirt
them with mustard and ketchup to keep
away
You Gotta Wear a necklace of grilled
onions otherwise I'll get you are we
done with this
all right a couple more
pickle spears could have went there
he could have I was I wouldn't have
recommended it
not every joke has to be made that joke
sucked and for that reason I'm out you
got to kill him with silver dollar
pancakes
[Music]
can I say this come on can I give you
this what the silver dollar pancake can
shuck my pee pee they suck man well it's
just a little guy they suck they suck I
want Flapjacks three fat ones
silver dollar get out of here yeah I
never got that we had them we had the
ancient mimo Frozen ones one time oh
they ain't bad that ain't good they're
awesome dude those freezer burned
instantly those things those gotta
freezer life about 13 hours those
started come home from the store freezer
burn they started popping around the
Foley household I would say 38 of them
mid 2000s when my dad was dropping my
cousins off at school where they might
hit their mom would drop them off at the
house because she had to be she was a
teacher she had to be in school early so
the boys would come over
they got a little bit better than what
we had as a kid it was always just
straight egos for us now but Patty used
to she'd get the Frozen you read the
frozen french toast yeah that wasn't we
were what that was European dog oh man
no French toast my stepmom made french
toast for the first time in-house that I
could that was all right you gotta have
french toast made at home I think the I
never had a good french toast in any
restaurant I've ever been through in my
life I think I didn't like French toast
because really uh no like the Frozen
stuff because they served it at school
like either in the morning or lunch and
it was like gray and I remember taking I
was trying to cut it with a [__]
plastic fork that won't happen then
[__] I was just like yo [__] this
[__] then right away it was just turned
off but I remember I caught a bunch of
[__] as a weed Buck I was a big ego man
right sure we all were it's like a roll
for breakfast yeah I mean this is
glitching get close you can get to a
buttered roll they were all right now I
remember catching a lot of shade I
believe at a buddy's house a lot of heat
in the morning because I came down and I
was like what do you on cereal we got
Eggos or whatever you know nice little
[__] Saturday morning thing with the
mom or whatever sure
I caught a lot of [__] because I
buttered my Eggo waffles is that normal
yeah right I remember I don't know they
made me feel weird like they just went
straight up
that's crazy I know that I was like what
else are you doing yeah
then add to Sarah oh man those bites
with the chunks of butter not melted and
the syrup
amige yeah it's a book about this cherry
cherry cherry it's like having waffles
on the Rocks all right dude that's my
favorite we were using margarine too
back in the day so it spread real nice
shout out the promise yeah it's butter
or peanut butter if you're nasty that's
crazy I don't think I've ever done that
dude I remember coming home it's amazing
coming home from school you know
whatever 13 years or whatever however
old young fat kid no food in the house
mom ain't gonna be home for about maybe
she was working third shift till [__]
12 45 at night so I had the whole I had
to figure out after school snack and
didn't on my own sure man and crushing
about four five six [__] Eggo waffles
dude I was just eating them like they
were [__] tortilla chips just [__]
sitting there have a screamer cold Coke
from the garage and just [__] biting
them they were I toast them and put them
in a paper towel and just sit there and
[__] crush them dude they were so
good straight up Plain Jane feel the
texture in your mouth you know I had a
good mouth feel they're all right I
wasn't too impressed with Belgium
waffles when I first when I first when
they first came across the radar with
the whipped cream and the fruit get the
[__] out of here give me a slice of butt
butt yeah this is America baby yeah
um
and they last for about two seconds what
the Belgium you gotta get them quick you
got to eat them in the kitchen on the
way out to the table yeah now I I'm not
a well we had a waffle maker at one
point we had that grilled cheese maker
at one point the equity sandwich maker
yeah that's what we had my cousin Kelly
used to bang out ham and cheese in them
oh like an artist I just remembered it
seemed like such a process mom didn't
like doing it no yeah we weren't allowed
to handle it type thing we were real
young he was like nah probably a QVC
purchase
um but yeah that makes sense this one's
a back to Burger wolf do you own any of
the four dummies books
like Autumn I can't you know how to fix
a car for dummies how to you know coding
for dummies which is a for a while that
was a dead giveaway you were an idiot I
thought those were Waldo's to be honest
with you it's the same dude on the cover
that's a uh it's a guy that looks like
Waldo sure I see what you're saying a
little bit I don't think we ever had out
that was like
they were we've talked about this before
that was a cliff notes to me they were
nobody in my family read anything ever
my brother
bread Patty and Terry did not read my
mom would read like
and what are they those John Grisham not
like maybe back in like those thick ones
Angela's Ashes I remember was floating
around for a long time every Irish
Dirtbag read that yeah yeah that and the
Diary of a Geisha or whatever it was
called
no yeah what was the name of that book I
think it's Diary of a Geisha Fifty
Shades of Gray I'm not talking on oh
real freaky Memoirs of a Geisha Memoirs
of a Geisha yeah Angela's that that and
the secret was floating around oh that's
Devil's play for us the secret you're
nuts given to the universe this is the
thumb just across the odd remember the
father Son and the Holy Spirit will ya
get out of the winning team but yeah
boys are putting up numbers oh let's go
yeah no we never know books no
encyclopedias there might have been
there was a real old dictionary floating
around for a while being encyclopedias
uh the only book I do remember ever
buying and liking from like the school
book uh fair right they would have like
the book fair yeah you get 20 bucks or
10 bucks or whatever go buy a book or
two for the year I bought uh the
Guinness Book of World Records that's
not bad oh man that's a good time as an
eight-year-old Two Fat Guys on the
motorcycles the tall guy yeah [__] uh
just annoying my mom with facts I was
like that kid and Jerry Maguire just
[__] dropping snapple facts on you
all day I don't know whose they were but
we had a pretty sizable National
Geographic collection stealing from the
dentist probably no I don't know who the
[__] collected them because I don't ever
remember seeing them build up or getting
delivered and just remember one time
just finding a box of them in a closet
somewhere
couple of racy picks in there yeah I
remember seeing a set of kids they'd do
it for you it'd work not these that I
saw free internet dude to set a can some
knee knockers playing heavy heavy nip
heavy bike nips on them some tummy
titties oh man if he's talk about a
burger wolf chick with a basket on her
head man what do we gonna do nah these
were top I remember looking at them in
they were I mean the highlights was
already figured out so I had no reading
so I grabbed the national Geo a little
kitty with his putting his glasses on to
crack the Highlight yeah that's what I
was doing it was a [__] word search
somebody had all circled all the words
sorry about Highlights magazine yeah I'm
talking about highlights yeah that was
my [__] that was my Playboy back in the
day oh man Goofus and Gallant was all
right I was on a bus one time with a
crackhead next to me with a word find
Circle and nonsense that's a good time
ah got another one boss it's like Lloyd
Braun selling computers on her arm
synchronized sips right there I know we
get called on that a lot yeah people
pull the people pull it out say we're in
The Matrix afterwards
um let's see here this is from Mickey do
you have any open containers in the
fridge currently
open like something without a lid never
I'd leave a piece of eggplant in there
that I told her you can't do that
and plus she puts back open cansome
that's [__] dude I used to live with a
buddy who did that I'd tell her botulism
half a soda and then no no I'm talking
about cans of food I'll do that from
time no you can't do that she does it
with tomato paste and does it with
refined refried beans do I put that [__]
in a [__] Tupperware Tupperware you
can even give me TB some aluminum it's
like Doc Holliday stacking around the
apartment uh well I'll get i'll get
I get lazy with the fridge and to the
point where it's like I get this is you
know we're pretty we're pretty jammed up
at the moment I caught her keeping
onions out there today after cutting
them I gotta put that in the fridge no
it's fine put it in the fridge yeah well
I I mean you know obviously my broads
from the uh from Europe is European
they've got school they got a different
me everything went in the fridge growing
up everything good every single butter
everything went though I mean everything
went in the fridge for us butter in the
syrup and she leaves stuff out and I'm
like what are you doing I'm gonna die
you keep this [__] out yeah
I don't I don't like any of that give me
coal give it to give it to me cold
leaving a sandwich out for a little
while let everything soak together I'm
talking ahead about it half a pie
dominoes or something that gets better
with time you know what I mean look at
the air here oh yeah you gotta let the
air here let that cheese congeal a bit
um you gotta Chuck it in the fridge no
no ruin it you put it in at night then
when you go to bed you know that was the
first round shout out to my boy Pat Uh
his parents the first time I ever seen
it done was leave the pie in the Box in
the oven sure yeah storage not hot
and then you just go we got pizza right
here man mulching on a couple slices
from Aldo's good night
oh so there's there used to be this
thing we used to call it the the plague
whereas there was this you know this
pizza place that we always went to
and there would be times I don't know if
I don't know what it was like 30 40
years ago whatever you would you'd have
a slice and then
you know someone if there was like five
of y'all having a slice somebody at some
point got well you'd be out skating or
riding bikes or in the woods smoking
cigs or whatever not nowhere near a
bathroom you get hit with the plague we
call it the Aldo's plague dude and this
thing crap up and hit hit you like a ton
of bricks for your opinion out of your
butt oh man and you would just so you
would feel it and you would see it in
their eyes and go I'll go back to your
house man you'd [__] try to Sprint as
far as you can get I caught a little bit
of food poisoning last week I'm not
really sure where it came from I got a
little taste of something
man brutal just brutal I don't mind it
it's kind of cleansing a little bit sure
you know a little bit of liquid IV sure
straighten out a little bit okay clear
my head you know what I mean man get all
the bad juju out of my body I crushed
one of those the other day uh
uh we went out to dinner and I had a
drink or two so maybe like a week or so
ago man I was dying when I woke up
hit me with a thermos of that laying
there on my side just
sucking it out right back to night night
land oh barely skipped it you're on your
side looking for wives I've seen a I've
seen a semblance of that it ain't a
great look man
um all right let's see this one from
Chad is it garbage to own a shopping
cart ours came with the house that's
wild oh man
what kind of house did you buy that came
with a shopping cart that's what I want
to know yeah this is a half a porch that
ain't good that's how bad what
probably very beneficial to have around
that utility wise what are you doing
until you can't put that on the grass
what do you mean no I'm saying if you're
like I don't I mean I don't know the
layout of the house I doubt it's a
[__] an apartment I'm saying if you
got a you know moving stuff from the
house to the garage move it's got to be
beneficial for sure it's a wheelbarrow
it's a grill yeah it's everything I'm
telling you it's a toy for the kids ride
it down a hill a ramming vehicle to get
inside the front door when she locks you
out yeah she's gonna I'm on the side of
it's probably benefit it's probably a
decent pool around the house from time
to time you have a shopping cart in your
house you're on the first name basis
with the local Smokies they pull up and
they go Greg Greg what are you doing
with the cart
yeah yeah I don't mind it I gotta be
honest with you it seems all right
that's a tough look dude um this one's
from Nick never have one red ten dollar
Amy is it garbage or call a rotisserie
chicken a bachelor's handbag
[Laughter]
ah you do feel dainty when you're
carrying it you feel you feel a little
fancy you know what I mean you're
walking around because you got to be
gentle with her too so she don't leak
off I told you the one that we used to
get when I was a kid from this place
called Country Butcher came in a bag it
came in a foil bag like the way it's big
now though like the way the Popeye's
chicken sandwiches come used to come one
of those man just [__] rip that thing
open did you see the one that somebody
tagged Us in from uh
what's the one in Boston not Stop and
Shop Market Basket Market Basket with
the tier two of them on the thing no
he's just one wrapped in like a thing
that you would they would wrap like a
T-bone steak in
like it was in one of those boats oh
yeah and then do the chicken wrapped in
that everybody was hit me I was like
dude that's gonna leak man that ain't no
good you need the airtight Dome on it
which I agree with dude that was dude
that would have been melting that
[__] that ain't good A lot of people
were backing me up on the the meat on
the bottom that's called the oyster meat
on the bottom
oh
no that's called an old kitchen sponge
to me
give me the white meat also nobody
believed that you've never eaten a whole
rotisserie chicken either people were
[__] in my DMs like who does he think
he is I have it man I've never crushed a
whole bird sure honestly I believe you I
had duck the other day that was awesome
that's the fifth time you've told me
that today I don't know what response
you keep looking for it was that good
duck
shout out to the Peking duck house in
China uh-huh China
Jesus Christ when did you get back they
turned me Chinatown I'm sorry this guy
go all the way China for a free meal
[__] talk about a goddamn turncoat I
trust you
can't get you for a fight the classified
documents a little straight yeah
a couple of shumai and I'm in now we
were we were in Chinatown
walked into Chinese New Year didn't even
realize it it's going down to get
something to eat that's anything that
happens in New York like walking
somewhere and you realize there's a part
and you're like oh no man this could
Jamie up for two three days man I hit
the panic button real quick drag and
chasing it down the street what the [__]
oh never mind happy New Year everybody
that's not that peyote kick back in
yeah it was a good time though man it
was all right you're the rabbit boys
you're the rabbit look out Kevin this is
all about freeze pipe baby ripping too
let's talk about it you know what I hate
I hate the burning in my throat I hate
the cough and I hate the wheezing when
you ice that baby down it's smooth
sailing do yourself a favor especially
made glass you pop it in the freezer
when you're ready to get down you're
ready to Boogie you pull it out yeah
when you're ready to get lifted if
you're tired of harsh smoke coughing
attacks chugging water after every rip
it's time to upgrade to an icy freeze
pipe that's what are we talking about
here freeze five unique line of
freezable glass pieces remove chest and
throat burn by cooling Smoke by over 300
degrees there you go it's the only way I
smoke Bernie's now
freeze pipes bubblers and hand pipes are
twice as smooth and half the price of
the other guys bongs quality made though
beautiful products the secret is the
freezable glycerine chamber that come on
every piece back in the day you'd make a
little pipe out of some tin foil like a
dirt smoking a tender now they got a
glycerin Chambers on them not too shabby
oh man
aliens aren't talking Alzheimer's
huffing on a coke uh so for a premium
smoking experience at everyday great
prices and free shipping visit thefreeze
pipe.com use the code garbage for 10 off
your next order that's the freeze pipe
t-h-e freezepipe.com code garbage save
10 shop today your lungs and throat well
thank you now back to that child back to
the show
this computer is huge I'm not used I
don't have my computer today this
thing's like [__] it's got T-Bones
whackbook I know Jesus Christ swears he
hasn't used it uh-huh which that's a lie
uh for uh
um pleasure time yes I I haven't cell
phone dude I gotta It's gotta there's
gotta be a lock on it face ID I believe
him a little bit I mean this is company
property technically
the speed on that thing
I mean the internet is pretty quick too
yeah it is
um I don't do that anymore though what
I'll watch those videos sure I've been
off yeah
I get off
uh uh all right let's see here uh
this one's from Ryan first time long
time has anyone in your family made you
slash your relative's tires because they
were trying to drive drunk when I was 12
my uncle had me do a little needlepoint
on his girlfriend's golden Accord one
night Whoa man that's uh just take her
keys Jesus Christ lock her in the
bedroom something that's crazy because
like I all although I do know that
argument of like dude give me the like
trying to get the keys out of someone's
hand like dude what are you doing just
[__] I gotta get home I got my I
gotta feed the Goldfish or whatever
you're like dude [__] go to sleep
it's already four you'll wake up you'll
get up go feed the Goldfish then it
ain't that important to get a home gang
no drinking and driving out there all
right be responsible there's nothing
more annoying than a blacked out person
I mean I've probably been that guy
before for sure trying to you know but
it's like dude what are you doing call
the [__] oobs or something back in
the day though in the 90s man I remember
seeing like older older like you know
Friends of the family are like ah John
Don no come on
and that was it back then that was it it
was a very different time to the point
where I remember they started putting up
the signs like DUIs are for real
like that was like a thing when they're
like you know they're finally gonna
start enforcing them it's like the
Easter Bunny back then I know I remember
there was like a huge Blizzard or
something like that and the adults all
started getting tuned up somewhere and
somebody wanted to drive home they're
like all right but it was like two feet
of snow so he literally was like
there was nobody out there one of the
homies got one in Chicago and everyone
was like how you never hear about that
happening in the city yeah I've uh
I've been partaking in a you know a
beverage in a car in the city not here
in a in a different city that I used to
live in yeah
and I got caught up by a cop next to me
at a light
and I was like I'll dump it out I'm so
sorry because I'm [__] with you and
just [__] blew a red light I was like
later dude shut your tires up kept going
[__] gave me fireworks told me to be
safe
yeah it's just like the city don't you
know obviously the you know cities tend
to have bigger issues at hand or
whatever don't want to deal with all
that people I think you could walk
around with booze in New York now nobody
would really give a [__] hey I don't
know uh I've never seen the heat that
much rolling around like they used to
yeah never really see it I don't know
I'm not on the subway Subways like I
used to be though I'm not riding the
rails like a [__] goddamn hobo from
town to town they were dirt bags down in
the West Village at night with their
souped-up cars just [__]
doing that [__] [__]
I was like where the [__] are the cops
get these [__] what I mean
take their cars slap them around a
little bit they're [__] losers with
that [__] yeah I can't [__] stand it
[__] firecracker
[__] dork it's a Saturday night what
are you doing it's getting laid probably
no they're not talking about that he's
sitting there with a bunch of other
[__] losers in a line revving their
engines people got work in the morning
[__] dumb I hate that [__] you're the
coolest guy I know I know Jesus Christ
trying to eat over here
somebody started yelling at him like
you're a [__] loser he's like nah man
that's money [__] screaming back and
forth to each other
I don't know yeah I mean I it is
annoying but it's like kids what are you
gonna do yeah it's also I mean
I don't agree I don't disagree with you
but this I tell you to get off my lawn
if I can afford one yeah you do you know
you do fall into Old Man Foley sometimes
walk around the beware dog sign in my
back it's always like you know he always
got someone new you don't like and it's
usually for them not doing it like them
these goddamn bikers or these goddamn
pedestrians wow
you're getting older I can tell because
you always got a bone to pick with
somebody getting real crotchety yeah
really really letting the Young
Generation you know yeah let them have
it open them up
which I don't disagree with needs to
happen from time to time sure
uh made by rock and roll
Still Rock and Roll you love that Harry
Styles though I love Harry Styles he's
all right
um all right let's see here DJ Van Damme
uh I believe from La Jolla if I remember
correctly the Van Damme family remember
them the wrestlers of course shout out
to the van damn shout out to the van
diesels down there in southern San Diego
what was your go-to underage drinking
spot I assume Barr let's do bar for the
first one and also how did you used to
procure at a pro the place used to
procure at a younger age this is good
this is good so our setup was
um
freshman year of high school
we had uh
our group of guys and a group of girls
all right that was a little friend group
um one of the girls
whose parents did really well and
traveled every weekend they were gone
every [__] weekend
she was a freshman her sister was
probably 20 21 would watch her we would
all sleep over at my buddy Eric's house
on Friday and Saturday nights and just
go over there in the middle of the night
we'd all like literally 10 of us would
sneak out like the dirty dozen and
[__] go down the street make a lot of
ten but yeah go over there and and booze
the sister would hook it up
um then when we started to get into the
age of fake ID and maybe
um an older relative that we kind of
looked like there was a place in
Norristown called uh I guess I shouldn't
say it they're still in business but
they've re-upped there was a place that
we used to go it was like a corner bar
that had to go be here that's a big
thing in Pennsylvania I don't know if
you ever think they have it up here uh
no not really don't the most a lot of
bars in you know bars in Pennsylvania
have takeout where you can go and
there's like coolers in the front
they're only allowed to sell uh up to 12
packs because Pennsylvania is a Quaker
State
and that's all it's all those Puritan
rules sure the the government the state
government sells all the liquor you
can't buy oh you can in a few places now
they started selling wine and stuff but
you can't buy liquor anywhere but a
state they call them State Stores now
now grocery stores you yeah but that's
still a department of that's still like
under the wing of the state and you're
all you're not allowed to buy the hard
liquor it's only wine and beers oh yeah
that's right
um I think so they they're
playing with it in some places or
whatever but they're yeah they're called
you go to the state store they're closed
on Sundays there's one in like the five
Town radius it's up so it's like on
Sundays and you also could used to not
be able to buy cases of beer on Sunday
the beer distributors were closed so
Saturday you would have to [__] get
your beers for the Sunday you know what
I mean unless you were by then unless
you'd go you'd have to buy like [__]
10 12 packs if you were parked sure so
if you're getting after it so that was
big you could always go to like try to
get takeout at like a dive bar that
didn't really care if you had something
that that was for us to get underage to
get some bevies yeah yeah shout out to
Ran's Liquors on Montrose and Ashland in
Chicago I was 20. I went in and The
Walking Dead had just come out and I
heard I walked in I was a zombie
real lady killer huh and the guy behind
the counter was talking to his brother
family owned spot about the first or
second episode and I just watched it so
I was like oh man that show's so good
when we're chatting him up about The
Walking Dead my kids wouldn't shut up
while I was watching it though so I
watched every episode of the first time
so I knew what I could so I had some
conversation to keep it going Ah that's
pretty smart that's good but 20 I mean
you're right there we're [__] high
school we had uh where are we where were
we where were you scoring and saw the
freshman and sophomore year my boy had a
Michigan ID yeah there you go damn in
high school in a Michigan fake ID oh
yeah and then let that fly in North
Carolina in Massachusetts oh oh that's
right I'm busy I'm visiting family I'm
staying with my aunts from the Navy yeah
we had uh we had a place in Somerton
that we would drive to about 10 minutes
from the crib and it was in August we
needed booze to go down the shore
because we were procure the booze at
home typically and then take it down
ashore across state lines real bad ass
guy and uh that was always the thing if
he got jammed up by the bridge you'd be
you know sure you know because you're
not a lot you weren't back in the day a
lot of cross state lines with it the
cops would sit there uh and try to jam
you up that was always the lore but we
would buy it in Somerton and we sent my
boy uh Vinnie with the skinny it was
about 15 16 we were driving so 16 at the
time he was Italian he went through
puberty probably about you know eight
and a half years old full body of chest
hair so it was August so we sent him in
in a wife beater and board shorts to be
like and like just had cash to be like
if they ever ask them for ID like I just
ran from the pool or something there
wasn't a pool and there wasn't a pool at
a 10 mile radius like I just came from
the pool you know I don't have my ID
just squirting it with a hose so we can
go on a beer run he's got flippers on
and goggles I just came from the pool
swim lessons
put his head in the microwave give him a
little tan he didn't need it he was
Olive
um
so then we had to you we had to send
them in in a wife beater into like
January you know what I mean to like
keep like hey remember me you know what
I mean it was like that old bit of from
Half Baked uh so he would we would just
send him in and he got cool enough with
them that that was the that was the plug
for a long time head down to Somerton
bed and then I got an ID the parents was
was not a bad move if you were smart
with it but you can never get enough
yeah I was like that you first of all
you it was too risky you were rolling
the dot also I wouldn't get in trouble
if I drank I would get in trouble for
taking their beer more than drinking
their beer sure you know what more than
underage drinking they're like you
stealing might be like you know it'd be
that we uh my buddy's dad drank Porter
I don't know what that is a porter oh
I'll Porter yeah yeah
[__] bottles of that out on the back
porch not even refrigerated uh more and
beer was I think it was a Yingling
Porter if I'm not mistaken I could be
wrong I thought I think it had like
seeds in it it was like drinking a fig
newton it's [__] brutal dude yeah but
it's a trip when you're chasing the
dragon back at a young day you got to do
what you got to do you know we used to
do Night Train what's that night train
wine after we get get that from the
state store I don't know how we were
able to pull that off but we did one
bottle of that you were good we would
just do cases uh we went through a bunch
of phases it started
with MGD sure called Liquid Gold sure
and then switched to okay High Life
screaming MGD it's all right wasn't bad
it was great dude the mg bangers Liquid
Gold
uh we also did that's Miller Genuine
Draft we would do high life and high
life lights were [__] hard to come by
but faint taste highlights are all right
yeah the High Life lights were good dude
I don't know if I remember that yeah
they were tough they had instead of like
the red and the yellow with the red and
the gold it was silver oh real [__] I
think we would get ponies of them to
begin with ponies are all right
whacking ponies dude
um that Miller like Coors Light Le Bat
Blues we call Big and Tasties we do them
in a winner remember Molson came out
with Molson XXX it was like Google that
Molson triple X Drive I was in the 90s
when they started [__] with that 5.0
and all that no this was like heavy this
is before like ipas
did we you'd have to split a sixer with
somebody because you'd end up fighting
each other it was [__] bad dude 7.3
ABV
dude talk about devil's breath this
stuff was like motor oil
it was like [__] dude it was this [__] I
remember we would each get a sixer of it
I think the first time we did we each
got a sixer of it and I'm talking like
we all fistful in Flip's kitchen it like
everybody just got black I was with the
vulture bro what's your problem all over
nothing that's the one of the reviews is
two and a half stars and it says two and
a half it's got an aggressive mouth feel
yeah dude I'm telling you that's like
the tonic of beer that [__] bites back
dude
that's hardcore to high school kid yeah
yeah dude we were barely you know we
were you know I mean we were drinking a
lot but a lot of Coors Light and [__]
like that then you come in with the
[__] heavy bike a nice wine cooler
back in the day was a good transition
Bartles and James Secrets Seagram's knew
their way around a wine cooler as well
delicious yeah
but and then liquor too we'd always do
like cheap vodka or something you know
what I mean that was big remember
drinking Aftershock
oh yeah the the blue or the red uh uh
the blue had the candy in the had the
like [__] in it I don't know I just
remember I just know we have to shock
from Ireland that's what they all drink
that's their like uh Fireball or
something yeah yeah it has like it has
like red like rock candy in the bottom
of it or something there was something
in there yeah we would do like we would
do screwdrivers
we would do we would my buddy had a
couch in his garage his parents like
would you know kind of look the other
way or were oblivious I don't you know
one of those families are like I don't
know what the [__] they come out just
everybody's drinking out of Red Cups
we'd be doing screwdrivers of [__]
pop-off vodka and OJ Wawa OJ cranking
Marlboro Milds the blue like the the
medium Menthol they were all right they
were always buy one get one too with the
Exxon they were giving them away man
when those would go on BOGO a text would
a text to every dirt bag in Bucks County
would go out and we'd converge upon a
gas station just to [__] score free
Bernies
[Music]
um
and did I remember I fell through a
table piano we were listening to Billy
Joel I was cranking heaters in a
probably about a half a bottle of vodka
down and screwdrivers it's one of those
things where the ground comes up to you
you know what I mean like you don't move
you're like I'm chilling and then just
out of nowhere dude this this [__]
one of those white patio tables did not
stand a chance with my fat ass dude I'm
[__] boom right through this [__]
thing there's nothing better than
watching someone lose a fight to gravity
oh man
yeah dude there's some reason it just
it's like man it's uh it's like
Inception where like the world shifts
it's like that dude and it just [__]
building start folding into themselves
oh yeah it's one of those Ellie and
Pages running around yeah cranking six
on a dirty couch uh the worst singing
Piano Man you knew your buddy was jammed
up if they pulled up with a with a can
of Steel Reserve and a pack of checkers
what's Checkers oh they were like
discount cigs I'm pretty sure they used
the clippings off the floor of the
factory to make those things we didn't
have that we didn't even have uh
still 40s and [__] really until college
at Temple all you go corner stores we do
hurricanes [__] get you know a
hurricane to pre-game was like the
was it was the stand status quo that
would twist you up real good
beer pong with hurricanes good night or
something about in the thickness of
those the mouth feel of a hurricane from
old e we never did that really loved
oldie
get your head on straight I remember
steel reserves but advertise more grass
Now new with extra gravity I'm like
[__] space beers dude let's go
the [__] dude let's get lifted
extra gravity let's go yeah
I remember sitting in a dorm room with
two of them taped to my hand being like
what the [__] is extra gravity dude
let's find out in a couple of minutes
I'll find find out when I pee myself in
12 minutes
I remember we were playing Edward 40
hands and the R.A knocked on the door
and nobody can open the door because we
were [__] our produce all taped up
like ah one minute man I probably
thought we were jerking off together
laughs
already sucked what the ra sucked yeah
that takes a certain kind of Dork to
[__] sign up for I get you have to do
it if you need the Free Housing and
stuff like that I you know or the
credits or whatever it does it does
benefit people to take the position but
be cool man they would pop in don't be a
[__] narc they would pop in like when
you least expected it with the [__]
security guys at our school all of a
sudden they're like this guy with like a
radio in the [__] thing it's like do
you have a gun on you if not get the
[__] out of my kick rocks dude I'm
trying to get laid over here
um we would have uh we would have to
sneak beer into that we had it because
Temple was obvious you know obviously
it's in North Philly which ain't a great
neighborhood so they had you couldn't
just walk in the dorm you had to slide
your card in and you couldn't just bring
people it was like heavy security to get
in and they would scope you for Booze
they would be like ah what's in that but
you would hear like oh they're doing bag
checks or whatever it was real [__]
uh
they would get real tight with it so I
had a [__] great plan I would take a
dirty laundry I would take like a what
are they the hampers like the big sure
rectangle drones like the hardwood the
hard plastic ones and I put 230 racks in
there and then stuffed dirty clothes
around it and stuff and just carry it in
like what's in there look just dirty
underwear man doing laundry
we were getting all tuned up in my dorm
and we got a knock on the door and I
just gotten caught with a bunch of weed
and fireworks the same week there's like
fireworks in college
guys and losers so the horror they're
like I was like I cannot get caught say
hello guys from Michigan so I went into
the bathroom and I pulled everything out
from underneath the sink and climbed in
underneath the sink and hid while they
searched the whole place
dude
uh yeah man so my buddy the Diary of
Toby McMullen yo dude I watched from the
inside inside underneath the sink I
watched the drawer gets slid open while
they while they search [__] and for
whatever reason they didn't look
underneath I was [__] bricks dude
dude we uh we're down in Wildwood
uh Santa uh flips house we're probably
about
18 at this point we're all just drinking
at his house you know I mean there's
like I don't know seven of us just
hanging out drinking playing cards
whatever
and uh
playing drink games we get all [__] up
and me and Pat get into a fight
outside like we're outside smoking cigs
and me and him get into it everybody I
think gets into it but like
they call the cop the neighbor yells out
we're calling we're like fighting in the
street that's we would get drunk and
fight each other not other groups of
people like you know what I mean we just
get so mad and end up you know wrestling
or whatever hustling so me and Pat get
into it they're the cops we're calling
the cops so Vinnie with the skinny had a
you know two three four five run-ins
prior to this so he was you know he's
Persona on grata with the with the 5-0
so he's got to lay low so we're like
[__] we all run inside and act like
you know we hide the booze whatever like
oh we're just chilling here we weren't
just fighting outside you know and uh
cops never show up or they might drive
by but nothing happens and we can't find
[__]
an hour goes by nobody can find [__]
nobody can find skinny and we're looking
nothing not dude he's proper in the
garage in a trash can with a bag of
trash on his head
laughs
I was like [__] I live in a goddamn
trash can
[Music]
Vinnie what like now we think he's ran
away he got kid now we don't know what
the [__] the fuzz got him dude he's
proper posted up in a trash can for like
two hours
it's got wallpaper on him
he's painted like cinder blocks
oh that's great we gotta wrap her up
though on that ah that was a good one
gang we love you to death uh-huh come
see us on the road there yeah a lot of
dates she may be announced by now not
sure yet we'll see you next week